listen the two of you not the only
breakout star from the show I give you
Connells chain Connells chain now don't
Instagram page I think there it is and
people like tweeting about the chain to
everyone watching on people on a scale
of one to ten how badly do you want to
be the chain around Paul breasticles
neck I'm 11
I think she means on the on the scale is
my religion just a girl sat in front of
a chain ask you to be Colonels Jacob
this one I like this one I'm not even
joking though I'd shag that change
mechanically how that would work but
then then bad news arrived last week
where we read that day Co Co Jones had
lost Connells chain now I dispute this
poor didn't realize that I didn't lose
the chain what actually happened is I
had to take it for pickups because we
did some pickups actually you kind of
very soon before lockdown we did a
couple of pickups so I bought the chain
and Lorna our lovely costume lady she
kept hold a bit in case we need to do
any more and then recently she along
with a lovely note that's so weird that
I just have it what a very small house
condos chain right here great how many
followers really bad half Daisy Barry on
Instagram but it's not quite as many
beautiful
you
[Music]